hey friends et's resident lifestyle
expert here and you know what else is
here summer now you know i've got your
back when it comes to the latest and
greatest food trends and now i'm serving
up one super healthy super simple super
delish and super instagramable breakfast
that will fill you with all the
nutritious goodness you need before
having fun in the sun
drum roll please
the spirulina granola bowl
not only is it totally gorge it's also
vegan using planet oat unsweetened
original oat milk which has zero grams
of sugar and a richness that is just
so you know this is gonna be good here's
what you'll need to get this healthy
bowl in your belly starting with the
granola three and a half cups rolled
oats one cup raw unsalted shaved almonds
half a cup salted roasted pumpkin seeds
half cup flax seeds a fourth cup agave
nectar a fourth cup maple syrup half a
cup coconut oil a pinch of salt one
teaspoon vanilla extract and one
teaspoon cinnamon
preheat your oven to 275 degrees and
while that's warming up throw all your
ingredients into a big bowl and stir it
up so that everything is coated
extra points if you turn up the music
and dance while you do it
seriously i wish you guys could smell
this it's like a
cinnamon dream come true
anyway line a rimmed baking sheet with
parchment paper spread the mixture into
a single layer and bake until it's
toasted and dry but not burnt this will
take about 45 minutes to an hour so i
recommend giving it a good toss about
every 15 minutes
once it's done take it out of the oven
and let it fully cool now here's the fun
part combine four teaspoons of blue
spirulina powder with four cups plan it
out unsweetened original oat milk stir
and watch it turn into a rich dark royal
blue now pour that oat milk magic over
your granola in a bowl top with your
favorite fruit add some shredded coconut
and voila the perfect summer breakfast
[Music]